[Music]
okay hey everybody how you doing
i'm here today for this micro dose with
dr alfie bone
uh alfie is a lecturer in digital media
culture and technology
at royal holloway and his research
focuses on a lot of different things
including continental philosophy media
theory and what interested me about his
research was
video games alfie is also a founder and
an editor
and a writer at everyday analysis which
is a pretty cool magazine where yours
truly has published in the past
so if you get a chance you should check
it out okay
thanks a lot for coming on here alfie hi
ma thanks for having me it's a pleasure
to be here
awesome uh so i was just wondering a
little bit so what inspired you
to look at video games and you tell us a
little bit about
what philosophical or theoretical
interest they have to those of us on the
left
yeah um great i mean for me i would
guess i should start by saying that i'm
a massive gamer and always have been my
i mean like since uh my seventh birthday
i think it was i got my sega game gear
um which um you know set me on the path
to gaming and i've been gaming
sort of endlessly since then i still
play every day and
you know have no plans to stop but um
uh it was actually um it's actually
gamergates really in 2014 which um
because i had done a phd in literary
studies and in
psychoanalysis really in critical theory
um and
gaming had always been a hobby rather
than a area of study but it was actually
gamergate which kind of
happened in 2014 i'm sure most of you
listeners know what it was but a kind of
series of um harassment campaigns
organized by members of this let's say
4chan rights
um which targeted um various um
diversity
uh figures who had entered the gaming
industry mostly women
and a few in particular and basically
made this claim that video games
were becoming left-wing um and that this
was a problem from their perspective and
so on
um and uh you know this was fascinating
to me in a lot of ways and i think that
since that moment really the
relationship between politics and games
has been
you know palpably clear in the public
eye whereas before that they kind of
existed the idea of games as escapism or
or not or apolitical but you know from
from gamergate onwards
into the trump election where you get
the kind of emergence of gamer
communities as
a voter base and things like that um you
know so clearly it became apparent that
games and politics were
much more deeply connected than than one
would have thought and at that point i
decided to you know dedicate uh
some time to to study that that process
the politics of games really and i think
that that they really can't be
overstated how important games are in
the kind of culture wars and then the
relationship between the left and the
right and actually
perhaps most importantly in the
relationship between the left right and
liberalism or capitalism
yeah you know it's interesting because i
remember back in i guess 2014 2013
it was actually through gamergate and a
lot of controversy around video game
universes
where i first learned about the
alt-right and saw some of the kind of
proto positions of the you know
masculist movement let's call it uh
becoming articulated so just for those
of our listeners who aren't really that
familiar with the history could you go
into a little bit more detail
about what this is all about uh and how
maybe uh the kind of people were angry
about the rise of diversification in
video games uh later on became more
politically active
um you mean you mean about gamergate or
just about politics and games in general
uh yeah well let's start by talking
about gamergate uh
kind of what happened there in a little
bit more detail just for those who
aren't familiar with that uh since it
happened a little while ago and then
maybe talk a bit about how that
transitioned uh into a more
sustained political movement yeah okay
yeah no i think it's really interesting
and i mean
i mean the question of um of of
gamergate is
and its politics are actually quite
complicated i mean so basically it
starts with
it starts with this kind of indie game
depression quest
um which came out in 2013 and then i
think the
designer of that's called zoe quinn i
believe and then the initial turn that
was applied was conspiracy which was
basically a kind of misogynistic
harassment campaign against quinn
and basically the essential claim here
was that um you know
she was just a target really ra of a
wider point that
um uh that actually games shouldn't be
political that
that games should remain uh about skill
about um play but should stay away from
political influence and you know this is
this is really fascinating to me and the
reason why i
i wanted to and then of course that it
caught more steam when anita sarkeesian
was the target uh who had a big youtube
channel and
um you know regularly uh her whole um
her whole stick at that time was
pointing out um you know anti-feminist
tropes in in games and things like that
so
yeah i remember sargon of akkad was
obsessed with her for a little while
yeah exactly you know but what interests
me is less is less than misogyny i mean
of course
these are concerns i mean of course and
i get your connection between the
alt-right is very much there
um and and then there is a lot of
prototyping of what we
refer we started to refer to as the
alt-right in 2015-16 and so on
uh there is a lot of prototyping for
that in gamer communities and things
like grieving which is the pro
or salt mining which is the process of
going into a multimedia
multi-multiplayer online space and and
making people cry and then
screenshotting those
evidence of those tears which is the
salt that's been mined and post
posting that to image boards you know
this has a long history in gaming and
actually
you're absolutely right that the
alt-right has it's it's kind of
the gaming community in some ways con
included
incubators for these kind of alt-right
online communities which coalesced in uh
in in the first trump campaign um
but for me i mean i don't think that
gaming is right-wing at all in general
uh or completely so and the community's
certainly very diverse so
i'm less interested in in that
particular aspect of it
than i am in the assumption that games
could potentially be apolitical
because what struck me as fascinating
here is that uh you know
might why i thought i'm gonna have to
say something in this debate is that
games have always been
deeply political uh and you know one can
go right back to the beginning that the
first
ever games are stupid little things i
think the earliest sort of electronic
game is this kind of cathode amusement
ray
cathode tube amusement race thing but
it's basically like a shell
heading towards you and you have to kind
of you know
press the button at this exact time to
block the shell soon after that you
start seeing okay there's early games
which are sports
it's like tennis for two um you know
coming out in the 50s
and things like that which i guess you
could say i mean of course sport is not
a political but
to a certain extent this is not the most
politically important thing um but they
say but then soon after that
when you get into the 60s and you start
seeing things like ace invaders and
berserk and
in the 70s and things like that you it's
clear it's clear that the games are
being produced in america
are in are coming straight out of the
context of the space race
uh anxiety spheres over russia and its
own developments
comparisons between the you the west and
the east you know there is no game which
is a political and and james never have
been a political you can even
you know even say that sonic is a you
know sonic's actually
because i always get people saying what
about this what about sonic there's
completely innocent it's not political
but
you know sonic's a deeply political game
if you think about how it uh
represents you know you start in green
hill zone and everything is kind of uh
easy and uh you know peaceful and then
you release these kind of bunnies and
and
birds from a kind of technological
prison
and dr robotnik with his technology and
then as you move through the game the
artwork becomes more silver and less
green more dystopian
you know sonic is an amazing political
metaphor not not an innocent piece of
fun
and and this this is why i thought this
was a fascinating thing
and it's bizarre because actually people
at the in the industry still
insist that games are very political um
you know in 2018 i want to say maybe
2019
the division two came out uh by from
ubisoft and
the ceo of ubersoft was asked oh my god
it's a dystopian washington
it's about the decrepit old government
and the need for renewal
it's a kind of critique of contemporary
capitalism and what's happened in the in
the trump
years and the ceo of ubisoft is sort of
saying
uh no this has nothing to do with
politics at all it's completely
apolitical this is just about imagining
the city as a dystopian world
of course we can see that the motivation
for saying these things is they don't
want to alienate half their
potential um you know sales yeah
they could target audience um but
but the point i'm making is for a long
time there has been an assumption that
games could be something
away from politics escapism fun play and
you know play and fun
and games are deeply political things
and always have been
so what kind of seemed like was needed
after gamergate was less
it was less that games were becoming
more political and this was being a
problem
but that we were being beginning to
realize how deeply political games were
and there's a lot of potential and i
think quite uh quite
quite an exciting possibilities for that
uh for the left as well as
as well as for the right i think okay
now i definitely have a lot of questions
particularly about contemporary games uh
since i have some of my own thoughts on
this
but before we get into that i was just
wondering how much do you think this
assumption uh or really assertion i
should say
uh that games are just harmless fun is
right from a kind of liberal ideological
standpoint which insists that
we have a private sphere uh that's the
sierra of what we typically
call recreation uh and that's apolitical
or neutral
uh and shouldn't be interrogated uh let
alone by the le through the lens of say
critical theory
right uh or do you think that there's
other factors at play
no absolutely i think it's absolutely a
liberal
rhetoric and i think that it's very
important to to think about this
relationship between games and the right
and the liberals let's say because
you know this whole game of gate thing
was structured around a load of mis a
load of
let's say miss assumptions about what
the relationship between the left and
the right is
and it's not it's not people's fault for
making those assumptions it's because
our media present
has spent years and years presenting to
us in this way but um
games were not becoming more left-wing
they were becoming
more like liberal ideology um and so
the right was targeted was was
describing uh
these patterns as left-wing as they
continue to do in politics today
when in fact what they are is liberal um
and
the left is accusing these things of
being right wing when often what the
fact they are is
liberal um and and so i think in some
way there's this kind of situation with
gamergate where
you know the left is saying oh my gosh
these games are fascist and violent and
they're
they're all right wing and then the
right is saying oh my god these games
have diversity and they're there for
left-wing
you know both camps completely wrong
in those arguments and the fact was that
games were completely and dominated by
liberal ideology um you know a
contemporary
neoliberal ideas of capitalism and
things like that and of course that
makes sense because that's the context
from which they emerged
so it makes it made a lot of sense that
both both people on the left and the
right were frustrated with something
that was happening in the games industry
and also it's a it's therefore uh
precisely the situation we find
ourselves in now politically
um where i think people i think are
starting to realize that um
you know in some cases um there's
there's more shared ground
between the left and the right than
there is uh but
insofar as they both have a massive
problem with the
kind of liberal status quo um so uh you
know i think that what what kind of
culture wars and debates play out in the
gaming sphere
around game of great and subsequently
are also those which are kind of playing
out in our wider political world and
and of course games as the number one um
you know number one entertainment
industry now bigger than the film tv
music industries um you know of course
they are the site at which the culturals
are going to be fought out and i think
you are seeing people
across the political spectrum picking up
games as
um not not so much as a political tool
this is not about propaganda and
convincing gamers to agree with you and
making games that is going to convince
the gamer to do what you want i mean
nobody thinks that corbyn run the little
mario with a corbin head game by a
company called games for the money
is going to create a new wave of corbyn
voters
but at least that the games are directly
engaging with politics and i think
people are actually seeing that the
culture was
being thought out inside this space uh
whereas of course the liberals as you
pointed out in your question
the liberals would rather it was seen as
an apolitical space um because that way
um you know well they continue they can
they would these well these cultures
don't do the labels much good to be
honest because they they
see the left and the right gaining
ground um so they would rather it was
seen
as this kind of space of harmless fun
well just moving into that just so we
can ground this a little bit for
uh those of our listeners who aren't
like super big into critical theory can
you give me an example of a game
that kind of embodies these tendencies
maybe one that's reasonably well known
well i mean i mean of course all like
games i don't want to like
make general assumptions about video
games and say that one game embodies
games in general because
like you know like films you know you
can't you couldn't say that that
you know you couldn't give an example of
a film which embodies films but
but what i can do is point out some
examples where you know things
are often not they're often not as
as kind of diverse as they seem and
generally speaking underpinned
principles
like examples i think really interesting
is is things like
um uh something one example
i like to give is the example of the
kind of city building game tropico
i find that very interesting um because
it's it's very much about
sort of a uh in some ways let's say a
socialist or communist aesthetic like
you can build an
island uh you can build your city on it
on a kind of beach cuber-like island and
have a dictator with a nice little
moustache and a red flag and you know
you can call your city a socialist one
and and so on but in order to succeed in
the game you have to follow
um capitalist city building principles
like those of sim city or civilization
and the only way to
be rewarded on the level of game play
and to actually succeed in the game is
to follow a set of
principles which are fundamentally
capitalists and and don't
and and don't so he doesn't envisage any
other way of organizing or
or or organizing a city than a
capitalist way even if assassinate
presents it
in that way and i think this is a
pattern we do see another example would
be the series assassin's creed
you know i think that they moved clearly
from assassin's creed 3 at least they
started to move much more towards let's
say
wokeness you know you get a much more
diverse cast of playable characters
which is often
mindlessly celebrated in the games
industry um although of course it's good
to see that but it's just
it's quite gestural and yeah you know
and and so and you also always in
assassin's creed always play as an
oppressed class and
you know attempting to rebel or fight
back against some sort of central
organizing force which is hegemony and
um you know corporate or uh
at least hegemonic and unfair governance
um but at the actual level that's all at
the level of artwork
at the level of narrative at the actual
level of what you do in the game it's
not
any different to any other open world
simulator nothing has changed since
assassin's creed one apart from the sort
shell uh in terms of what you actually
do to play it
um so so i mean so what we're sort of
seeing is games i would say i mean to go
back to the gamergate argument i would
say that
um it did look like games were moving
towards the sort of
liberal uh at the level of uh
story and artwork but they didn't
fundamentally change at the level of
play i think that's quite interesting in
the sort of theory
and and you know what so what we're
looking at is games making narrative
gestures
uh to be more woke um and more diverse
things like that
which is which is like i said it's a
start you know it's a start
um but um when when you actually look at
what you do in the game
it's you know it's absolutely none of
that
um you know so another example would be
just cause where the whole point is to
sort of destroy
cities you know this is sort of like um
you know property destruction game
it's quite interesting to create a
property destruction game um
but um it just does so in this
completely mindless way where like
your level of play it's exactly the same
as like blowing something up in gta or
something like that
um so what you what you see i think is
certain sort of patterns emerging
and a lot of um things that people are
fighting over there are just the
narrative just the shell we could say of
the game so i think that
for gamers this is a big question it's
one that people are thinking about now i
think how do we produce games which are
actually different to play
what would a socialist game look like as
a fascinating question for example
would it would it look like um you know
would it just be a shell you put on top
there are some exam
examples such as tonight we riots which
is quite a good game you know but it
very much
has gone for this kind of communist
aesthetic and so on papers please i
guess
is one that gets uh mentioned a fair bit
um an indie game from
2015 or even earlier than that um
and i think you know yeah this there's
movements towards this but for a game to
be left-wing
it doesn't just have to tell a story
that's like left-wing it has to be uh
an experience of play and fundamentally
different on the level of actually
playing it has to have a different
um algorithms underneath it than the
ones which um
you know reward the principles of the
gaming industry up until now this
actually leads me to a really
interesting question
um about you know wokeness and volt
capitalism because as you mentioned
a lot of the culture wars are kind of
fought over issues of diversification
which are fundamentally i think liberal
ideas in some respects right the idea
that we should be inclusive tolerant
uh so on and so forth without
challenging uh structural economic uh
foundations
uh and i'm wondering to what extent do
you see the rise of diversity rhetoric
in the gaming industry
as a positive development and in what
sense do you see it as in some ways
insulating or even upholding um certain
variants of vote capitalism which are
fundamentally exploitative
i i think that's a great way of putting
the question and of course it does it
relates to
the way corporations get behind um blm
and things like that and we are we are
obviously seeing
a very central moment for work
capitalism today
um and i you know i hmm
i suppose my what what what i was i
guess my more sort of official answer to
that would be something like well
it's just a tiny start uh in the gaming
industry because
you know clearly uh you know clearly why
not have a diverse range of characters
i'm not against it
i just think it's a tiny tiny start or
or maybe it's completely ineffectual uh
you know i
i don't think it's quite as yeah i mean
it's i
mean overwatch i guess it's a big uh was
the big game which was celebrated for
this
um you know suddenly one could be
represented
across races genders intersectional
characters um
and and you get to um you'd get to feel
but of course this is so superficial
because at the level of gameplay there's
that much difference between overwatch
and fortnite you know and so
uh you know you're not actually
experiencing anything anything that's is
constructive to building a better
society at all
and it's more about selling copies of
the thing so you know yes i can even see
the argument that
um this distracts this kind of vote
capitalism
distracts from the fundamental economic
issues
that are at play here and you know
something i think is very important with
gaming industry in this context
is and of course it's true of like nike
doing blm as well
um but you know um and this i'm taking
from a friend of mine mariandi galvatay
who's a fantastic critic of games and
she's
always been pointing out that you know
if you've got a feminist game
uh sure it's got a it's got a strong
female lead
and that that feels great but what if um
all the components that make the
hardware
that that game is played on are
exploited women working in chinese
factories who are underpaid and have
no uh no health care support and
terrifying working conditions how
feminists can again be
if it's fundamentally based on the
production of a completely capitalist
and patriarchal system
of exploitation so you know this is
where i am with of course it's the same
with
with nike's trainers and the blm side
there is a massive danger here that
we're going to lose sight of the things
that really need radically changing and
i think that
this is another answer to the question
you didn't even ask about what a
left-wing game would look like
but one would need to build it on a
different console for sure
and and and you would not need a p i
mean i personally think we don't need a
ps5 for example i don't want to play
grand theft auto 6.
i'm bored of that you know i would much
rather we strip back to
uh more affordable and more sustainable
technologies which we might be able to
use to produce
games which sure they might not look as
graphically wonderful but at least they
wouldn't be fundamentally based on quite
the same levels of exploitation that the
aaa high-level gaming industry is today
no i think that's a great answer okay uh
one of the things i thought was
interesting was starting in the 1990s
uh you saw a different kind of rhetoric
surrounding game creators i'm thinking
of people here like sid meier
or peter molyneux you know who's the
creator of uh black and white and fable
uh which was almost uh the clean shot of
rhetoric that you saw associated with
somebody like steve jobs
uh where these game creators started to
present themselves less as entertainers
or the creators of entertainment
and more like artists right but one of
the interesting things that you saw
associated with that is of course
uh they weren't just artists per se uh
they were also capitalists right they
were creating
a product in the kind of way that you
were talking about
and i've always had mixed feelings about
this because on the one hand
i do think it's important to start
treating games as a kind of artwork
uh rather than just as a piece of
entertainment uh precisely because once
you start thinking about them as works
of art
uh they can become under scrutiny for
all the different reasons that you're
talking about
on the other hand i really resist the
idea of
glamorizing the figures who create these
uh as somehow
just engage in a purely creative act
dissociated uh from all the kind of
productive uh problems that we're
talking about right
how are these games created are they
created in an unexploited manner and so
on
uh so can you speak a little bit about
this and do you think that it's
beneficial
uh when game creators are seen as not
just you know kind of producers
uh and capitalists but as creators in
some sense
i think this is a really interesting
question and um i do i do have an answer
but first i just wanted to say that
i i don't know what this means but it
occurs to me to point out that
that way in which games get attributed
to a kind of alter
figure um it seems to come from the
board games and tabletop games
communities
where it's it's very conventional that
uh even today when a new board game is
is produced it's very conventional that
it's it has the name of the
the game's author creator uh almost like
an author of a novel um
and then there's very much a culture of
this person's games and that because
there's a kind of alter
creation of tabletop gaming um and that
seems to and that that map that's
come over to things like as you say syd
mirrors things like that
seems to be those games which have
actually got a history in the tabletop
strands of gaming as well which is
pretty interesting um
however i think that there's a massive
difference between creating a tabletop
game and creating a video game and it's
precisely because of how
embedded it is with the industry and
with capitalism you know it
to a certain extent if there's an indie
creator who's made a game entirely on
them
on their own to a certain extent okay
one could see that point
but for me i'm with you for the most
part i'd rather we didn't think of games
like this and this is what i was trying
to do in my book really but
to think about games and this is why i
chose um one of the reasons why i chose
psychoanalysis as a way to think about
games because
i think that games are a combination of
things
and they are not and i tried to
playfully make this idea that we should
use freud's um
theories of dreams to understand games
because when you go into a game you're
kind of in a semi-conscious dream like
state
but the problem is that um and that and
of course dreams are deeply political
things but the problem is that
the game is not your dream but it's also
not the dream of its author and this is
where i'm coming to answer your question
it's not
it's not one person who sits down and
then imagines a world like watchdog's
legion
it is a dream or an experience of play
which is made by the culture around it
it's made by
elements of capitalism it's made by
artists of course the diverse range of
people involved
from art artists to designers to concept
um people um you know through to
screenwriters actors and so on but more
importantly than that it's a product of
its
kind of cultural moment and this is i
mean of course you could say that about
literature and you could say it about
film
but i think with games even more so
these are collaborative symptoms
of um corporate capitalism and its
view of its authors and its creators and
its content producers
um so yeah i'm with you that it's it's
much less useful to speak about games as
as being the output of one individual
creator or author
and because i think we should see them
as cultural symptoms like if you play
something like watchdogs legion
just doubt um you know it's we're all
responsible for the existence of
something like watchdogs legion you know
because
it's it's a symptom of our society and
our culture and i think that's how i
would
would think of them and and rather than
as
works of art produced by one or a few
individuals i guess
well just you know to kind of push back
a little bit on this question
uh around 2007 is the first moment i
should actually say uh maybe around 2001
when peter monolinium produced
uh black and white but definitely around
2007 with the release of bioshock
that was around the first point where i
noticed that games were overtly aspiring
to produce something that had a certain
level of
thematic and artistic sophistication and
you know bioshock is famous for this
since it was
kind of a critique of uh randy and
capitalism at least according to some
individuals
and now you have games like red dead
redemption uh you know which kind of
aspire to
the kind of pulpy grandeur that you
would see in some of the old westerns
things like unforgiven uh or you know
other clintons with classics like the
spaghetti westerns and so on
do you see this as a positive
development or is it problematic for a
lot of the same reasons
that you mentioned before this
aspiration to tell
something to say something important or
make a statement with a game
hmm yeah i mean
i don't know it's a very good question
uh matt and you know i mean
so so with this reason one of the
reasons why i keep mentioning this
this new watchdogs game is because um
i've been playing it because i was asked
to be in it so i'm actually in there
um as a voice actor i suppose but um
basically having the same sort of
conversation i'm having with you now so
what they did was they reached out to a
load of sort of uh journalists
and philosophers of games and got them
to record podcasts which you can listen
to
within the game in the kind of in-game
radio you know so like when
just like in gta when you're driving a
car around you can switch to the talk
show station
and then you can you know you can you
can hear me talking about this kind of
crap
[Laughter]
but this interests me because at first i
sort of felt like well this is quite
a good sign because and it's by ubisoft
too i mentioned how that when the
division two came out they kind of
denied
that it had anything to do with politics
so it seemed like there's been a little
bit of a change here in
in the case study of one company like
google software they suddenly
saw actually these games are part of
politics and therefore perhaps they
um they could be making a political
point um and let's say let's
like directly um you know politicize
them by bringing politics and discussion
of politics into the game itself okay so
when i first heard they were doing this
i thought yeah this is good
um and i was you know i was obviously
pleased just on a narcissistic level to
be involved in a big game like that
um but then you know i've been playing
the game which i don't like
and and and
i think that no i mean it's it's it's
it has its merits of course but i think
that um
you know it's a very um bad um
case study for representations of
rebellion in games um
so you know it basically presents
rebellion as
um you know what's really nice about it
for those for anyone who hasn't played
is that there are no there are no heroes
essentially the whole concept is that
there's like nine million playable
characters so every londoner
every londoner can be recruited and so
in some ways it's trying to go for this
kind of grassroots
like okay anyone can be a revolutionary
um and i like that i think that there's
some really things to its merit
and and that's interesting um but at the
same time all it all it's um
all the way you sort of recruit people
is um
basically you do them a favor and then
they'll join the revolution uh
so and it's it's just as easy to recruit
a um
a uh um like a guard
from this they're called they called no
that's i can't what they're called now
the
albion the you know the absolute enemy
guards that are the kind of tech silicon
valley
uh mercenary army that keep your city in
uh um
yeah in check um as it is to recruit you
know an anarchist
which is completely ridiculous um but
also um you know it's it's basically
gamifying revolution it presents
revolution as
self-motivated and the result of
carrying out a certain number of tasks
correctly
and obviously issues of gamification
there's a lot to say about it but
but the point here is that you know
games do depict revolution all the time
that's the in vogue thing
right ready player from ready player one
onwards you know just
cause watchdogs legion and acute where
you basically play as these little cute
rabbits that
go on protests and but these depictions
of revolution are completely
they never depict organizing
organization it's always just um
destruction
symbolic acts of destruction of a a kind
of uh
centrist uh dystopian government and
they never
build into their gameplay and structure
anything other than
anything like organizing anything like
ideology you know like how would we
actually go about getting a rebellion to
happen
it's always just like i just blow up
this landmark and then you know that
gives you five points towards the
revolution or whatever
you know and there's so much creative
potential in games there's so much
greater potential in games too
to to think about new ways of organizing
right new new ways of structuring worlds
building things creatively
and that just never seems to be sort of
taken up so i suppose my sort of
long-winded answer to your question is
that like
um you know it depends on every game but
um for the most part i think what we see
is this kind of celebration of the
aesthetics of revolution
with no useful steps taken towards
thinking about how to actually organize
and create any
kind of change so i i see it as really
sort of
almost fetishizing uh how revolution
looks
and how it's presented as this kind of
wonderful joyous experience which is
also fun because it's a game
but but staying really um stopping short
of actually
uh taking you know encouraging us to
think creatively about different ways to
organize
absolutely and i think in that case this
shows the efficacy
of the old cultural industry thesis the
pioneer by adorno and hurkheimer amongst
others
and when they talked about how it is
that the culture industry can assimilate
revolutionary potential and commodify
them
uh sometimes in surprisingly creative
though of course noxious ways
and you know a lot of people have talked
about how it is that punk music uh
or rap you know early 80s rap early 90s
rap have
fallen victim uh to this process of
modification by the culture industry
uh and it's probably not that surprising
that revolutionary impetuses would be
commodified in the same way by the video
game industry
um but moving on i just had a question
uh
actually about kind of conservative
approaches to games because this is
always where i become a little bit
reticent
about criticizing the video game
industry too fiercely
uh and it's because i feel that
sometimes uh if
there's a temptation sometimes to engage
in kind of conservative elitism
towards video games which is essentially
to kind of
replicate this liberal gesture but on
steroids by saying that video games are
inherently a debased
mass product they can never have any
kind of aesthetic interest in and of
themselves
um just because they don't write like
rise to the level of something like
hired you know the toll stories
dostoevsky's or whatever it happens to
be
right and this has always struck me as a
very kind of
noxious elitist uh aesthetic aesthetic
gesture
that i can't support right on the other
hand
i am resistant to the idea that
anything produced under current cultural
and material conditions
by the video game industry can genuinely
express
revolutionary thematic points in the way
that you're talking about
so this kind of puts me personally in a
bind when it comes to my the
interpretive framework i'm trying to
apply
uh to video games because i don't want
to move to elitism on the one hand
or brand in my critical faculties on the
other so how is it that you think that
we should approach
kind of threading this needle per se
yeah
no i i certainly um i certainly see the
point and and you know i
i'm always um quite careful because i
mean what i do as well a teacher
degree in video game art and design at
royal holloway university london and
and here i'm always very conscious of
them
not coming across in any kind of form of
elitist way to the students and
certainly not coming across as i
i have done in the past kind of
accidentally as somebody who thinks
games are bad and we shouldn't play them
because they're inherently doomed to do
you know i i don't think that at all and
i don't think that
i don't i don't even think that we
shouldn't shoot people in the head with
sniper rifles i think that's fine
and i think you know gta for example can
be i mean some aspects of gta are
horrible and
and um you know horrendously capitalist
i suppose i'm not so bothered about the
violence arguments myself so not
interesting to me
but um but some aspects of gta are
really interesting i mean
like if you think about it as an
artistic representation of a city and
how
it writes class politics into its city
um
are actually fascinating and there's
some great art projects which have
shown that there's a fantastic artist
alan butler who's an exhibition of just
still screenshots from gta 5 which
frankly look like real photographs and
and make visible the class politics of a
city and it's
it's fantastic and this is within the
very game which so easily and often gets
dismissed as the most mindless and
debased one
um so i think that each game is quite
diverse and has
various aspects to it and we shouldn't
be um you know we shouldn't dismiss them
in that way but to answer your question
a bit more directly you know i don't
think that
well i mean i do think that like you
know the revolution can kind of come
from within
um you know i don't think that we are
gonna the aaa gaming industry
is going to lead the way in ushering in
a new
form of socialism absolutely i don't i
think it's already
too far gone um but video games are
quite a diverse thing
and and the question of play um and you
know like
everything from the way we play our
cities to the way we
we live has become increasingly gamified
and the kind of the kind of um
line between games and reality is sort
of thinner
than ever so i think i think that um
games do represent a chance to think
about different forms of social
organization
i mean we can even think of gamified
things like um
food waste applications where you get
in-game rewards and
things for instead of spending money on
food from tesco or sainsbury's whatever
supermarkets you guys have over there
um you get them work from other people
who are
food that's going out of date and stuff
and then you get little points and
rewards for that you know it's
gamification of the city
in a way which is kind of at least in
some way useful or environmentally
useful at the very least
um so you know and then likewise in in
in actual
games that are more immersive let's say
you can have at least
attempts to imaginatively and creatively
think about different ways in which
society could be organized
so and there's no reason why those would
be you know so there's so when you think
about
the political potential of games you
know i don't think we need to we don't
need to go all the way to saying that
like
you know games are gonna you know big
hollywood games are obviously not gonna
usher in a new form of uh social life
any more than big hollywood films were
likely to do
but um but that does that but at the
same time
uh you know there are so many different
ways to use gaming and the technologies
of gaming
to experiment with what socialism could
do with technology going forward
um you know and and how how enjoyment
how pleasure how play
um could be part of uh a a
a society that was organized differently
i think you know games and gaming would
very much need to be part of those
discussions well actually
this is a great segue to the next
question i had which is uh there are
some conservative marxists and they do
exist
i know who've interpreted the formation
of gaming communities as they called
including game communities in virtual
way uh as merely a sign
of people's alienated subjectivity under
neoliberal capitalism right
uh and oddly enough some of these kind
of conservative marxists almost adopt a
reactionary alarm where they say well
the reason people are entering into
these gaming communities
is because they're alienated by the
conditions that they live in uh they're
not so-called real communities
right uh and therefore they can't really
have any kind of
tremendous social meaning in the lives
of people that make them up and i've
always been resistant to that
right uh on the other hand it's hard to
figure out
where exactly gaming communities or what
exactly gaming communities are
and what kind of sense of community
meaning and solidarity they provide for
the people who
participate in these communities and
some people are very invested in them
right so i was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about that
uh and secondly can you talk a little
bit about how it is that
i suppose reactionary gaming communities
emerge uh some of which have a very bad
reputation i'm thinking for instance the
starcraft community from back in like
the early 2010s you know was very
criticized for being
highly exclusionary elitist uh very bro
dominated
and so on and i say that since i was a
member for a little while
yeah no i think you're right and i think
this is
this is really important um and it goes
back to what we've
sort of touched upon earlier on in our
chat about how i think what happened
with with
when i said that gaming communities were
sort of suddenly
um people realized they were there when
they all came out to support trump
um and suddenly there was this almost
untapped voter base and that tapped into
what you were saying about okay people
are there in gaming communities because
they're alienated and
you know but this is um i think this is
something to drop entirely really
um and the idea and for me this is why
games are so important and it's another
of the reasons why
i decided to you know start writing and
dedicating my career really to thinking
about games
is that you know games are no longer a
subcultural thing
um so i'm i'm less interested in games
as subculture and i know there's a long
history of that and
you know i've heard from and discussed
some really interesting people um i was
recently
interviewing um a um street former
street fighter esports champion who's um
transgender and
felt the opposite of this idea of gaming
communities that the one that i put this
question to her that you've put to me
i said you know isn't honey's like the
most misogynistic right-wing
communities that you can find often and
she said that you know her
experience of life in the arcades in the
in the 90s um was the only
uh aspect of her social life where she
didn't feel she was you know judged and
and
and that she was accepted precisely
because she was good at street fighter
and nothing else uh so there was a
certain kind of diversity in those
communities that was
was interesting for her um you know so i
think that's interesting
so i think that one of these communities
are probably not as um characterized by
pepe the frog as we might think uh and
because that's the ones that get the
the attention but my main point is that
gaming shouldn't be thought in this way
anymore you know more than 50
of the world of gamers and that goes
through to africa and everything you
know in
countries where they've not long had
high quality internet
rural china uh african gaming's grown
massively
and there's a there's a massive um move
towards agenda
balance now as well although of course
certain games are still played by
men more than women but generally
speaking it's about 50 50 across the
board
and so what basically looking at is a
whole generation of gamers
um so you know and games are our
essential part of how we all grow up and
this is where also
in a different conversation i'd say more
about psychoanalysis and how
we need to think about subjectivity and
a little bit more maybe something like
cybernetics theory and
plasticity um you know catherine
malibu's idea of plasticity and how
our brains are changing and the next
generation you know my daughter's four
and a half she plays video games very
very well
clearly that this kind of plastic brain
idea applies here and that
you're becoming a different uh group
different subject
the gamer is no longer a niche identity
on the forums
in the basement of their mum's house the
gamer is a description of what it means
to be
a a basically a a subject
in 2021 you know and and increasingly so
for the future it will be
something inherently connected to
everyone's subjectivity and
you know even if you don't play video
games which is basically no one
you you do it does affect you your life
is gamified you use
apps which have features of the video
games industry in them
you use um you know various products and
your whole city is affected by games you
know
architects are using them to build your
buildings doctors are using them to
train their staff you know this
game games are everywhere and so i think
it's in some ways useless to think about
uh gamer communities uh of course there
are millions of different types of those
with millions of different politics
um but generally i think we need to
think about games as something which is
um the mainstream now and having a
mainstream impact on how people think
and feel
and uh if you think as we have kind of
intimated
that for the most part liberalism and
capitalism are the discourses which are
winning out
in this massively influential
transformative genre of
uh media then clearly the left would
need to
get itself involved in those processes
to make sure that something as massively
influential as games
doesn't just transform us into
increasingly capitalist subjects
no i think that's very well said and i
imagine that there's partly a
generational factor at work here
uh not to give into kind of uh cheesy
generational politics right but
uh somebody's pointed out to me that you
know uh as the boomers kind of age out
uh that means that you know gen x
millennials consumers every single one
of them are growing up
in an environment where games were
widely accepted to be part of the
popular culture
right and people's everyday lives so i
think that's quite significant
but moving on to like my last question
uh this is kind of a cheesy one but i
think it is important to ask
whenever i bring up these kind of
cultural criticisms of well-known
pop culture uh products right uh whether
movies or games
uh popular books uh at least a few of my
students uh or people i'm talking to
kind of react viscerally to it by being
like
look you know why do you have to ruin
everything you know what i mean i just
want to go home for my work you know
from work
uh sit down with my video games play
them and not have to think about
something and now you're telling me that
these are interpolated and all kinds of
systems of exploitation
and we have to start considering things
like gender and racial
uh differentiation amongst characters
and so on i just don't want to have to
deal with that crap
and i think that we all feel that way
sometimes right uh i'm a fan for example
of the marvel movies because i grew up
reading comic books i like comic books
and i kind of get a thrill from seeing
them on screen i'm very well aware
of their inclusion within a massively
exploitative
hollywood system that tends to
perpetuate certain ideological tropes
uh that deny our capacity to think
revolutionarily about the social
conditions that we live in
so how would you respond to people who
kind of just push back and get a bit
about this
that way right that look why do you have
to be a pain can't you just let me enjoy
this
you know uninhibitedly yeah well let me
let me answer it from the perspective of
a gamer instead of uh a theorist or
journalist or whatever
um you know i i um i i've been playing
games as i said
since i was seven which i guess uh yeah
i'm 33 now so it's a fair chunk of time
um and you know um i i do
play indie games but also you know big
mainstream games would always have
throughout that whole
short history i guess um and i can say
this i'm bored of the games themselves
and i don't think i'm on my own you know
when when it's
a new assassin's creed or even when it's
something that's not
you know that's not been out before like
this new cyberpunk game
um and uh you know or it's a new
civilization or so these are classic
games these are great games they were
they were incredibly fun
um in their time um and um
but i think that um we get we're
actually getting quite
bored of and any gamer knows that across
such a range of games there's certain
things that just get inherited and
move from one to the other and it it's
it's actually quite rare now that you
find a game which is
quite new and quite um and generating a
kind of fun that's
that's that's that's that's interesting
enough to sort of keep you
going and you can put it they sort of
seem to be designed you can put
hours and hours into something like
assassin's creed but you're just going
through the same process you've been
through again and again and again
and i think that um you know thinking
politically about play
um and realizing how political play is
is going to and is already producing
much more diverse and fun
uh games so i get the point that one
doesn't want to always think about it
but come on it's not difficult once you
put your headset on or put your
controller on it's not difficult to
forget right you can still have a
conversation about um
the economic patterns that the industry
is implicated in and then still
get into the immersion of the game and
just enjoy it for what it is
right but i think by actually being
politically critical of games and their
and their underlying structures
we're going to see more fun not less
okay i think that's a great answer uh
well thanks a lot alfie for coming on
i mean this was a lot of fun and a
really interesting conversation uh first
sunday afternoon
uh is there anything you'd like to close
on we always like to give our guests the
last word if possible
no it's been really nice to come on um
you know if people want if listeners
want to check out our new project it's
called the popular show
they can find it it's a kind of show we
talk about woke capitalism it's
basically a bunch of lefties who are
looking to work out the relationship
between liberalism and the right we get
some really weird controversial guests
on
um and we should have you on as well
sometime matt we're only we've only been
doing it about three or four weeks we've
only had three episodes uh we're on
you can find us on youtube and and uh at
the popular show
uh and check it out and you should come
on and join us for a chat
one day matt i'd love to uh okay well
thanks a lot alfie and uh we hope all
you're doing well
stay safe in these [ __ ] up times and
yeah this is matt from the philippines
it's been really fun uh
[Music]
cheers
you